j'ai mis libre ainsi les classes rime en
tous les cas je me serais très bien vu
par exemple intégrer la maison blanche
[Musique]
puis on a envie de savoir qui est votre
fantasme
je suis tombée amoureuse de lui quand
j'étais gamine ce qui est des massilia
alors voilà lui
photo acheté cher ou pas voilà il est
beau de toute façon c'est un acteur
exceptionnel il a un charisme d'un
accord maintenant interstellar j'étais
franchement et il a un nom de mac do
parce que vous êtes jaloux d'orgueil
lorsque je m'appelle bac à duda c'est
pour gala ça serait pas mal
ouais elle c'est vrai que clio c'est la
seule où c'est crédible
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jean michel bayle mois celle où silviu
ally mcbeal les bandes tahri kill bill
sa sublime et pas mal pas mal oui vous
avez vu que même pour voulons qu'une
photo gratuite elles sont toutes
gratuites
gilles verdez et eva longoria eva
longoria elle était venue ici sur le
plateau et oui et j'ai l'impression que
c'est moi qui l'avais qui fait ni l'un
ni l'autre mais alors je peux vous le
dire après s'il vous plaît si je peux
vous le dire après coup c'était une
vanne couvé oui aux normes et à l'écrit
venue sur le plateau on lui a fait une
vanne on va dire qu'elle a des qui fait
que je râle m'a appelé mais non mais
sinon mais si des mini vans a été due à
un smack avec elle non mais je vous
explique et après elle a été désinfecté
je dévie bien sûr l'actrice mais moi
c'est la femme qui m'intéresse et je
pense qu'on aura des choses à régler
ah oui et cela est bien mais franchement
ça passe ouais maintenant il a servi à
sarlat ah oui américain des saints row
ses goûts c'est la seule crise de dix
réussites
il a aidé à me caruso jeune fille se
souviendra il est un peu bouffi par
l'alcool
il revient maintenant d'accord c'est
franchement fait plus jeune que lui
ah oui mais le soir tu es beaucoup mais
vous vous êtes tous là sur le physique
phy moi je moi ce que j'aime c'est la
lueur dans les yeux ouais c'est ça non
mais c'est vrai tu étais où vous êtes
vous êtes oeuvre je m'en fous je suis
pas là dedans explique t on chez les
hommes chez les hommes alors gens des
hommes j'aime bien métiers de l'art moi
j'aimais bien d'enchaîner les records -
ou encore matthieu delormeau on a tous
envie de savoir qui est votre fantasme
alors où abat donc au moins serre à
cause du tout à l'heure enfin moi un
petit peu d'exotisme et c'est vrai qu'en
ce moment je suis attiré aussi je dois
le reconnaître je le concède par le
pouvoir
ah oui donc pouvoir et afrique du nord
elle est sympa vous coquins non j'ai mis
ma qu'obama libreville et classe les
beaux gosses
il a du pouvoir mais il sera bientôt
plus président oui bah oui mais alors
j'en connais qui sera peut-être moins
bien mais en tout cas je me serais très
bien vu par exemple intégrer la maison
blanche
j'avais déjà je pense que déjà vous avez
déjà à la maison d'arrêt baba pas s
envoler on dirait un film américain a
laissé version lego les séries on dirait
barack obama voilà matthew de l'eau - le
premier ministre anglais franchement je
mets ions white satin
ouais ouais ouais on a tendance à
oublier parce que quand on se dit que
des conneries et voilà c'est ça moi
j'avais la même chose que cabaye bah
ouais mais ici j'ai un petit truc en
plus gilles c'est que moi j'ai rencontré
panneaux et j'ai un rendez vous avec
elle
eva longoria ouais une vraie photo sipa
le montage les mais c'est ouf c'est une
photo etc eva longoria et elle était
elle aussi aux alcooliques anonymes
[Musique]